so for more on this let's bring in dr
nicole sapphire um
here's a here's a statement about this
in the numbers it says at this pace 6
million americans
will have been vaccinated by the end of
january and at that point the first
doses will expire
even when kept in the complicated deep
freezing system required for the pfizer
vaccine
and that means that millions and
millions of crucial doses of vaccine are
going to go to waste now that's kind of
infuriating
what do you think the problem is
well absolutely dana i mean right now we
have about 500 000 americans being
vaccinated and yet our supply
we we are shipping out several million
vaccines every single day
so while we're stockpiling all of these
vaccines they're not actually being
distributed so therefore they're going
to be sitting in those freezers
and there is a shelf life on that they
cannot stay in those freezers over a
certain amount of time
so what it has to happen right now are
the states really need to ramp
up they need to they need to elicit the
private sector a lot more right now they
haven't been doing that
they started out by only giving it to
certain hospital systems and then they
gave very tight restrictions
on who was actually allowed to be
vaccinated so all of a sudden it turned
into this very complex distribution
process
when really it should been all hands on
deck we give it to the hospitals
we get the pharmacies the private sector
involved we do these pop-up sites and
anybody and everybody who wants a
vaccine should be able to get one right
now
i'll tell you in new york city dana
about two there have been two pop-up
centers in the last 24 hours
and people were being turned away
because they didn't have an appointment
yet people were lined up for hours and
governor cuomo said that he's identified
over a thousand sites for these pop-up
centers they should have been
mobilized last month i don't understand
why they're only
now being looked at they haven't even
been opened yet dana
it's experience it's very frustrating
you know there's so many people that
want to get it so they can get back to
work
get back to their lives and travel i
also wanted to ask you about this
because
there is some concern i understand that
excessive alcohol might actually affect
the effectiveness
of the vaccine what do we need to know
well dana we know that
chronic alcoholism is absolutely an
immunosuppressant and even in mouse
studies it shows in
alcoholics the flu vaccine may be less
effective
so chronic but chronic alcoholism is
very different than
moderate to binge drinking alcohol
there's a bbc documentary that's being
aired i believe tomorrow
where you had a researcher who checked
white blood cells that that makes the
antibodies
before and after drinking three glasses
of prosecco and the results showed that
there was about a 50
decrease in the number of those
circulating white cells
um after the three glasses of prosecco
now that being said dana we don't know
by by any stretch of the imagination if
having an
three glasses of prosecco is going to
decrease the efficacy of the vaccines
likely not but i can tell you chronic
alcohol use
binge drinking absolutely will have an
effect on immune system not only may it
kind of thwart some of the efforts of
the vaccines
but it also will make you more
susceptible to infections specifically
pneumonia so you really want to
watch that alcohol intake especially as
we have seen a rise in the frequency of
drinking throughout the course of this
pandemic
all right i'm just thinking of greg
gutfeld teasing me about three glasses
of prosecco i'm sure i'll probably hear
about it on the five
dr sapphire thank you